nous allons faire une demande de mise en
liberté avec eux mais tu restes avec mes
potes à forest dans la logique des
choses puisque au mois de juin
effectivement je m'attèle laval a
complètement changé sa version il met en
avant le fait qu'il n'est pas l'auteur
de la mort d'alexis 1 et que dans la
logique des choses c'est toujours comme
ça qu'on procède dans un dossier
criminel lorsqu'une personne revendique
son innocence mais il est bien évident
qu'une demande de mise en liberté
la sphère johnattan d'avaler traités de
la même façon que n'importe quelle
affaire criminelle dans laquelle on nous
aurions à procéder de la sorte
donc c'est tout à fait normal pas
présumer ce qui va se passer mais
la remise en liberté sur internet peut
être délicat pour sa santé à lui par
exemple c'est quelqu'un qui est assez
fragile il ya plusieurs questions qui
vont se poser d'abord par paul juge
d'instruction bien évidemment on va
analyser cette demande par rapport aux
faits même si c'est pas l'objet de la
demande puisque c'est avant dire droit
et deuxièmement il ya des paramètres de
l'article 144 bis que je considère pénal
on se pose des questions et notamment
des questions sur la sécurité de
johnatan laval qui vont naturellement se
poser dès bien évident que ce n'est pas
une demande de mise en liberté pour
retourner à gré qui sur la région degrés
mais que nous avons si d un autre
département est un lieu et une situation
géographique suffisamment éloignée de
gréer suffisait totalement inconnu du
grand public pour être suffisamment
rassurante sur une possibilité de sortie
john hutton
je ne dis ben il va moins mal si vous
voulez je ne va pas bien
ça reste toujours très difficile cette
détention il est toujours à l' isolement
il ya toujours des voyages au smpr il
reste surtout jour particulièrement
negri et lesquin évident que c'est une
situation très compliquée pour lui très
compliqué pour sa famille aussi